Alon Girmonsky, thank you so much
for joining me on the show.
How are you?
I'm good, Michael. Thanks.
I'm very good.
Okay. In two words,
what is it like running a startup
in corona times?
Give me the ...
Crazy.
But startup life is crazy
so it's not that different.
Wonderful. Okay.
Alon, like I mentioned
right before we started,
if I were to list all the companies
that you've been involved with
in acquisition, whether it was
companies that you founded,
was the CTO, VP engineering,
or anything of that sort,
we wouldn't have been able
to fit it in 20 minutes.
But I am going to ask you,
can you just give me
a really brief rundown
where you came from
all the way from when you were in Atudai
in the Israeli Defense Forces
all the way up until now
when you are running UP9.
Give me the brief rundown.
I'm not sure I can do that
because when I was actually at Atudai
that was too long,
my memory doesn't serve me
that long ago.
But no. I'm the normal kind
of Israeli startup nation story.
What does that mean?
It's a playbook, right?
That we all go to the military, right,
meaning the good guys go
to ... and guys like us,
we go and build things
more programs and stuff.
So, I started there.
At Atudai six years,
nine with school and everything.
Did my own startup.
My first startup was good.
It was okay.
Compel.
What is okay mean? Just for context
because 99% of startups just fail.
So, when you're saying okay,
That's okay.
It's okay to fail.
Don't let anyone tell you different.
No. So yeah.
And with startup life, it's very easy
to talk about your successes
but again, you won't be there.
You are not an entrepreneur.
You are not in the real startup life
if 90% of your experiments fail.
Right.
I don't know of anyone
that kind of okay.
You're just in them.
They can join someone
and then they will be successful
but that someone for sure
made many mistakes and failures.
- Makes a lot of sense
Yeah.
But on TechCrunch,
you read about the successes
and that's obviously the cognitive bias
that we now have.
But Alon, nevertheless,
you went through the
you're saying
the traditional Israeli route.
Going to the military
and doing some meaningful things there
not so much Tel Aviv,
but other very meaningful things.
And then moving on,
creating a startup that's okay.
And then you're involved
in a series of acquisitions.
And what I want to get out of these
next 17 minutes or so,
is I want to pick your brain
about a field or the subject
that we talked about,
whether it's the transitions between
employer or employee
versus like a founder or an entrepreneur.
What it means to build teams,
build products.
So, let's start with that first one.
What does it mean,
that dissonance between being an employee
versus being an entrepreneur?
Yeah, I think you coined it right.
There is a dissonance
because for whatever reason,
people look at startups and founders
and entrepreneurs and think,
"Hey, that's fun.
We should do that."
And then I turn to them and say,
"You need to have a bug.
You need to be somewhat crazy,
to actually want.
For years,
you're probably top of your class.
Very smart. Can do a lot of things,
but let's settle for half the take.
Work three times as much for half the pay.
Fail nine times out of ten.
So, you really want to do that"
So there is a dissonance between
how it looks like and how it is.
I can tell you that entrepreneurs,
at least from where I look at it,
they don't have a choice.
Okay? They cannot take orders.
They cannot follow instructions.
They can try and they'll probably
be good at it for a while,
but something inside will die.
So I think that's the main difference.
If you can get a job at Google, do it.
I highly recommend doing it.
Why do you recommend that?
Because I think this is, again,
I can't. I simply can't.
And if I could, maybe I would.
I tried meaning,
BlazeMeter my recent company, was acquired
by CA and then Broadcom.
Very good position.
Good company. Different company.
It's not Facebook, right?
But, I can't. I cannot.
When I had to choose -
what I'm about to do next.
When did you discover this
about yourself that you simply can't?
Long time ago.
When you try and try and try
and you rather fail
in an attempt of building something
because this is where you get the value.
You get the value
when you build something, right?
Right.
I rather fail there or be successful
for doing someone else's bidding.
Interesting.
Yeah. So for me,
there was no option other than
So now I want to extrapolate this,
and as you're building your teams
across the different companies,
I'm wondering
You're bringing on to your startups
oftentimes the early employees,
a lot of them do have that bug in
their eye.
They're also entrepreneurial.
They want to be a part
of the success story,
but you need to find somebody
who can take orders
and can fulfill your tasks
and your requests
even though they're having this
entrepreneurial spirit.
So, how do you go about doing that?
You tell me
because I wasn't successful in doing that.
No, I'm dead serious.
I have a team of 15 people.
They do not listen to me, right?
And no matter what I do.
I need to convince them
that what I see is right
and maybe they will follow, okay?
But, especially Israelis,
meaning they do not follow orders.
They talk back.
Right.
And for example in America,
this is something
that doesn't happen too often, right?
So especially with my team
that currently is mostly Israeli,
they don't do what I say.
It's very simple.
Yeah. Well but I'm sure that, again,
as the CEO, I mean, at some point
you do make a decision, right
And at some point you say,
"Guys, listen. This is our strategy."
I mean, you have a few responsibilities.
Hire the best people,
make sure you have enough runway
to continue the company,
and have a vision
for where the company is headed.
And at some point, there is a difference
between your understanding of the market
and where you're headed
versus employee number 15.
There must be, isn't there?
Maybe in employee number 500.
But, no.
And you actually said it
the three items.
One is, point to the vision, right?
This is what I do.
And you do it once.
If you're lucky, you do it once.
You can maybe do it twice or three times.
The fourth time you're out.
But you point to the vision
and from that point onward,
you explain, you pitch the vision,
and the more communicative you are,
people will follow.
People are looking for someone
to follow at the end of the day, right?
You fundraise.
That's the responsibility of the founder.
If you cannot fundraise,
don't bring someone else to do it for you.
Find a job, right?
Right.
You fundraise to create longevity
for the company. And then
you hire the best people you can.
And I added you can
'cause sometimes
this is what you can do.
But if you hire these people
and you explain to them
and they actually agree with you,
if they don't agree with you,
they will not follow you.
Right.
If they agree with you,
the dialogue doesn't need to happen
on a daily basis, right.
The North Star should be there.
Yeah. So what I'm hearing from you is,
a lot of it is trust.
But it's not just, I hear a lot that
employees need to trust their CEO.
Employees need to trust their CEO.
He sets the vision.
He or she sets the vision.
But what you're also referencing is that
the CEO has to trust their employees
because in the whole art of
talking back and bouncing ideas,
and when you're telling me proudly
that your team doesn't listen to you,
obviously they listen to you,
but when you're saying that,
what I hear is a proud statement of
my team, they are entrepreneurial,
they're independent thinkers
and they challenged me on my ideas.
And that's why we work so well together
because we respect
and we trust each other.
Is that right?
That's absolutely correct.
But again, everything I'm saying,
by the way this is not the truth.
This is not object.
This is me, okay?
So I've learned, I've tried to be
like the decision maker would.
I have this right hand
and that right hand,
and this right hand.
... my right hand, right
It doesn't scale, okay
And I survived that era
to a point where it's all about the why.
Right.
If I am able to convince you
why we are doing this,
you'll follow me.
I don't need even to explain.
You will have your own vision
and it's good enough.
If I constantly need to manage you,
we're in a bad place.
Totally. So Alon, what number
startup is this that you're involved with?
Oh my God. Come on.
I don't remember.
Is it after two hands?
So, are you asking how many companies
I have founded over the years?
Or no you were involved with.
No, no, no.
That's too many to count.
Especially in this day and age
where I'm also investing
but I'm investing in a company
that I can help at least at the beginning.
So I don't know, 20, 30, 40.
Okay, so Alon, what I really want to know is
give me your one or two earned secrets
after 20 or 30 companies
that you are watching
these scrappy, hungry entrepreneurs
and these great teams
because you're choosing diligently
the companies that you're either
investing in or you're founding,
or working for.
What have you learned over these years
that a young entrepreneur like myself
as I go along my journey,
I don't have to go to 20, 30 companies.
I can just listen to your advice,
and take it as it is.
Listen in a very limited manner. Yeah.
I've learned something that I was taught
meaning I had great mentors, right
Even though that when I started,
let's talk about the past 10 years
because I don't remember what was before.
It was too long ago, right
But I had great mentors, right
And they taught me
I said, "I know a lot,
but there's far more that I don't know,
and I want to learn from people
who actually know"
So one of the things they told me,
"Listen, it's all about you."
And I said,
"What? What do you mean about me?"
"It's all about you" Okay.
If you believe it, it will happen.
If you don't believe it,
no one will help you get there.
And I've learned this to be true.
I've learned that if a founder believes,
it's not about believing in God,
it's not religion.
If you can envision, okay,
the way you're headed
and you actually believe
you can go there,
A, you'll get there.
B, people will follow.
Okay?
So it's all about the founder
or the founders, right.
Co-founders.
So, I try to do it where I live.
Again I'm back to,
I have some experience behind me,
but I'm back to being a founder.
It's the same exact experience
every other founder has.
What becomes easier over time?
So now that you're a serial founder
and you've had successes behind you
and you're coming now with UP9,
what's easier than before?
What's easier than before?
First, I can tell you that
it's never easy.
Even when you think you know it all,
and you've done it all,
you learn that
because you're not doing the same thing.
Right?
So, apparently every story
has its own unique complexities.
Okay?
So, that's the one thing.
But experience does help you
because you know what to expect
on the other end.
And I think the one thing
that causes people to halt
is the fear of what will happen.
And when you know,
hey, we've been through that crises
and we've done that
and that customer left us
and this term sheet blew up, right?
And whatever.
You know okay, I know what to expect.
I know how to manage it.
I know how to compare it
to other kind of situations
I was in the past.
Having said that,
that helps you some.
You still need to deal
with the day to day,
with new
and that's the fun of it.
- Right.
So it's not a problem.
Definitely. And now you're investing.
We know each other through J-Ventures.
For example.
And you're investing
and at the same time, you're the CEO
of an early stage startup, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
And to be honest
How does that work?
It sounds so weird
that you're both investing
in early stage startups,
but you have an early stage startup
of your own.
Yeah.
The one thing you learn very quickly is
when you compare your time versus money,
invest the money.
It's easier.
You put it there,
hopefully you chose well.
Right?
And usually, I don't just invest.
It needs to be the founding team.
It needs to be the industry
that I understand.
So, it's not a guess, right
Right. Of course.
But it's easier to invest than,
for example, to be an adviser.
Interesting.
Okay. And to be honest with you,
I had far more time when I was,
in the past three to four years,
when I was an executive
in a bigger company.
Today, there's no time.
Zero time.
It's negative time.
But again, I'm enjoying every second.
I do support the companies
I have invested in
or am actively advising to
but I'm not taking, at least not
no more advisory roles.
Interesting.
Where do you get more energy from:
The investor in you
or the entrepreneur in you?
That's an easy question.
I took a decision, a conscious decision.
Should I go into investments
and help companies,
or do the not so logical thing
which is jump back in to where I just was.
Okay?
It sounds like that takes a crazy person to
go through all these ...
and then jump back in
and do it again from the start.
Yeah, but I've realized that
a long time ago.
So you have to have this
something in your head
and then you cannot avoid it.
Unfortunately.
Definitely. Okay Alon,
give me your two cents
about building products.
That's also something we mentioned before.
You've built quite a few products.
Give me the dos and don'ts.
When you approach a product
that you're examining,
what are you looking for
and what are some of the big pitfalls
that we can watch out for?
Yeah.
So, assuming you chose the market right
right
Assuming you chose the problem,
set of problem and solution,
that is kind of big enough to matter, okay?
When there is, let's say
you have a vision market fit,
the next thing is product market fit.
Okay?
It doesn't come first,
but it definitely comes second.
And I think this is critical.
And I think you cannot overinvest in this.
It's a period of time,
and everything is relatively easy.
Vision is easy.
Fundraising is easy.
Scaling is easy.
Product market fit,
if you do it right,
yes, everything else is easy.
If you do it wrong,
everything else become impossible.
And I think
that's a little counterintuitive
for I think a lot of people,
because when you look at
all the fancy YouTube videos
or all the lectures that you can attend,
most of them are how to raise money
and how to build a strong team
and how to how to how to.
But I almost never see a session
on how to find product market fit
and how to measure your NPS score.
How to know objectively
whether you've actually reached
product market fit.
Yeah. And you mentioned NPS
and other tools,
but I think that, we're all engineers.
This is good and also bad
because we have so many ideas.
One of the rules I had is,
you have an idea, I have an idea.
Let's forget about these ideas.
And you would say killing innovation,
but that's not correct, right
If a customer tells you that,
if the first customer,
the second, the third,
this is it.
This is what we are going to do.
Forget about your idea and mine.
Now, having said that,
customers don't always tell you,
they tell you what they want
not what they need.
So it's your job to hear them, and then
reflect back what you think they need
which will be the base
for a product market fit.
Yeah.
And I think that there's the funny quote
from the, looking back,
that if we had listened
to what customers wanted
back in the early 1900s,
we'd just make faster horses.
Agreed. Good example.
Definitely. Alon,
what are you really passionate about?
Fine. Yeah.
Startups, entrepreneurship,
all these journeys.
I got it. You're crazy.
But what are you really,
when you wake up every day,
what is the highlight of your moment
the highlight of your day?
Listen, I have a ton of things
I'm passionate about.
Okay?
And there are periods in life,
like electric guitar and stuff like that.
Anything related to music.
Cars, motorcycles, mountain bike,
road bike, anything
extreme wise, diving.
You know I had master, not master,
but three stars in diving.
I forget the degree there.
When you build a company,
there's no other thing.
24 hours a day, for as many years.
Right
At least that's the way I'm doing it.
It's very tough to keep a
life-work balance.
I have three kids, right, here
at home in Palo Alto and everything.
And I think that we are able
to keep a work-life balance,
but you wake up in the morning,
Slack, e-mails and stuff like that.
So, and I'm not sure, some people
I'm sure many people
will tell you otherwise,
but this is me.
And that was before.
And this is a period in time.
It's a few years that you don't,
this is it.
This is what you do and your passionate.
This is what I want to do.
I don't want to do anything else.
I love it. I love it. I love it.
Alon, before we leave,
the most important question.
I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
or that any of your employees
or current or past co-founders
would define you as.
So, okay.
So, I would define myself
as a founder and an engineer.
And I'm trying to keep professional
into the career, not
you know I love my family
and we're very much an Israeli family
and everything.
Yeah.
But I think an engineer and entrepreneur.
I don't have a third.
I know you asked for three,
but I know how people talked about me,
and not only employees, but customers.
Crazy CEO. Okay?
And just to explain,
it's not like everyone wants to be crazy
because it's maybe fun and other thing,
but always exaggerate.
Like you go into a show,
you're doing something,
you're expected to do this, do that. Okay?
To a point where actually
a prospect they came in and say,
"Hey, your CEO is crazy."
And I said,
"Good. I feel comfortable."
I love it.
Alon, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
It's such a pleasure.
I learned so much.
And best of luck with covid
and best of luck with UP9.
Thank you so much Michael
and awesome initiative.
I'm so happy that you reached out.
Thank you. Take care.